you have [__] Birdman passing you the
[__] torch officially on record
that shit's crazy
how did you like how does that happen
like like
um I don't know I just asked him to send
me something was in the studio and he
said he like that's what I want and he
was like I want to do this for you yeah
he just he told me the other day like I
won't be on everything you ever released
like
Birdman was one of the first people
believed in me though like two months
and three months until it happened he
called me like you the one like he
didn't try signing you did he tried to
sign he was the first person trying to
sign me he flew me to Cali we just lost
touch in like the next week or something
like that I had wind up doing say cheese
I ain't even know it would say cheese
but then Sean brought me to the league
when Capital One to sign me and then I
was going back and forth to live with
them so it like it almost probably feels
like similar to like a NBA free agent
feels like when they're trying to sign
to you know a team like how cool was
that just having like a little bidding
work going for you I don't know I'm
ready for the next one